where are you calling from right now i
like your is that wallpaper i love
whatever's behind you yeah
i i i can't take credit for it i'm
renting uh
working in in outside of london right
now and i'm renting a house and clearly
the
the family has a child which i do not so
it has become my workspace
um i actually love it yeah it reminds me
peter pan i like it my kids are obsessed
with peter pan uh well valentine's day
is coming up so and since you don't have
kids you're still having a really good
time
on valentine's day every parent
everywhere um is that something that you
get into no
no i don't i have my birthday my
birthday is february 16th
so i feel like it's not fair you get
trumped
yeah and um my fiance our
anniversary is right before then
and so and then his birthday's right
after so it's it's way too many things
at the same time
so we don't we don't acknowledge
valentine's day
oh my gosh that's such a shame i love it
i just love a reason to be like okay
we're gonna do something fun
um but i i hear i hear that you actually
have an issue with your hair
during zooms like what is this issue
because it looks fabulous
right now well i thank you
i you know what i did to prep it i put
it in braids
and sprayed some hairspray in it
because i don't know how to do my hair
but um i've been cutting my
bangs and that's been the biggest
problem with dull scissors
and i'm just every day they get shorter
and shorter as i do press i just
disappear into the bathroom and
paul bettany sees me and every single
day my bangs have gotten shorter and
shorter
that's oh my gosh it's always the idea
that i think sounds great
and then i cut them and then i hate
myself for doing so
i'm like why did i do it it's um anyway
your hair looks lovely i think that's
i'm gonna try the braid trick
want more fun stuff i thought so check
out these videos floating around my head
this one is really cool i'm just saying
no pressure